[Music]
the world was shocked when Beyonce
announced she's expecting it twins on
Instagram and it now we know her dad
Mathew Knowles was - I was shocked
let me tell you what happened I've got a
first text and I'm like why does this
person say congratulations
I didn't know myself on Thursday BAE's
father sat down with the insiders Debbie
Matenopoulos to talk the big news so
what did you think about the way that
she announced it to the world because
you know she always does things on her
own terms to thought she well it was
smart that was very smart that she did
it rather than someone else the media
doing it so I think that was a really
smart move on her part so how does it
make you feel that you're gonna be a
grandpa again three times over I'm
extremely extremely proud of happy and
full for Jay in her so and Blue Ivy's
gonna have some brothers and sisters
does that mean that beyonce is having a
boy and a girl oh I don't know I just
kind of threw that out cuz I didn't know
this boy or girls so you have to sit
brother and sister but there's a
possibility she could be having a boy or
girl
yeah all right how do you think Lou I
will be as a big sister
well Blue Ivy is already excited so you
know be honest and I had a great
conversation yesterday and I'm looking
forward to seeing her soon and I totally
look slowed down a little bit you need
to slow down a little bit so after you
saw after the news broke on the internet
yesterday you called her yes what'd you
say I was like she was like hi dad
I was like you're okay because she's
sound like a little tired because she's
been working not working on the Grammy
performance and we just had a wonderful
daughter dad conversation do you think
was she rehearsing for the Grammy I
don't know come on you know I don't know